and start with joe burrow who i think
was the bigger story last night i think
he set a record was it 37 a 61. there
you go
three touchdowns no picks it's hard to
throw 61 passes as a rookie with no
picks let's just point that out for it
it's hard to throw 61 passes what's he
doing what's he doing right
in general and he's been hit through two
games like 22 times he's been contacted
i think they call it so he's getting
beat up and yet he's making plays not
only looks like not only does he look
like the real deal michael yeah you know
when you take a quarterback number one
it's hit or miss
usually you're forcing that pick because
you need a quarterback and it happened
to be the best one coming out
those numbers if this guy ain't a sure
thing
i don't know what is
you know i mean i don't know that i've
been this excited about a quarterback
at the beginning of his career this
confident this sure about a quarterback
maybe this is andrew luck
you know i know it's not that long ago
but yeah you know you have a lot like i
said it's hit or miss with quarterbacks
you got some number one picks at the
question marks coming in and then they
struggle right out of the gate or but
you know andrew luck you just knew even
at stanford and when you got to the
league you knew he was going to elevate
that franchise
watch joe burrow you just know
let's go back to something else
you know we both grew up you know about
around a bunch of uh a bunch of old
people or what have you so you know we
were raised by a lot by village okay you
know how the old people used to say
grandmother
yeah you know what i used to say about
little children like they were mature
they had old soul oh he'd been here
before or she'd been it before you know
like joe burrow you're looking at me
he's been here before like he's
reincarnated like you know he's not a
rookie
he's lived his life before he's nice man
i really i enjoy watching him last night
and it was clear and even when they were
down early
he
i just felt like he was just doing they
weren't down because of him i thought he
was making good decisions
i thought he was reading the defense
very well he throws a pretty ball mike
he throws a pretty ball he looks good in
the pocket the only thing i'm concerned
about
the only thing i'm a little concerned
about with joe paul now yesterday we did
franchise mode on the cleveland browns
right and we're like how do you fix the
browns they've been through a bunch of
quarterbacks and
they've had a bunch of losing seasons a
bunch of head coaches general managers
on and on we did franchise mode on the
browns
as if
they're the only team in the state of
ohio that needs a little franchise mode
done on them
now because the bengals made the
playoffs that didn't win any playoff
games but what made the playoffs under
marvin lewis
they've gotten a pass because the browns
have been that much more ignorant i say
it on purpose they've been more ignorant
than cincinnati but this is a franchise
this the bengals have had some really
good players
uh they've had good coaches you know
historically paul brown bill walsh is an
assistant they don't spend any money
so i'm just they don't spend any money
when they need to especially in the
front office the scouting staff they do
it on the cheap and it's a shame you
know mike brown
come on you got that name you got a
responsibility you're paul brown's kid
you got a responsibility to do it the
right way i'm just concerned that joe
burrow is going to get caught up in
cincinnati business
and and he won't be his best self
because of the franchise he plays for
but i love what i see so far you
mentioned you mentioned marvin lewis i
mean look and joe burrow happens to
believe where the same number that
carson palmer once did and there was a
moment in cincinnati where it looked
like they had found their guy and they
were about to take their next step they
never quite got over it and carson
palmer eventually moved on after you
know he tore his acl in pittsburgh
against pittsburgh in that playoff game
um no man i actually i think this could
go well if zach taylor is in fact the
the young up-and-coming coach they
believed him to be and they draft well
especially offensive lineman if they
they fortified us off into the line
that's what i would do if i would
franchise in the bengals i'd be looking
at peyton sewell i'd be looking to try
to figure out i don't know if he's gonna
be bad enough to get him at the top of
the draft they got the kid at ohio state
they can get i'd be going straight
offensive line with like my first two or
three picks you know in the drama i'll
be figuring out how to protect that
investment that is joe burrow moving
forward i can't laugh at them anymore
actually
those those punch lines those punch
lines get them off now
because i think uh in a very short
amount of time i know they're owen two
but you can't take the cincinnati
bengals slightly takes one to no one
right there takes one another one lebron
sees it lebron sees it you know got that
it factor everybody sees it all off
season his teammates taught or whatever
whatever this kind of all scene these
season this was it's only so much you
could see but whenever they started
working together everybody saw joe
burrow immediately take command on the
flip side
on the flip side we're talking about
makers
looking good nice real nice uniforms
and the uh and it's hard to look good in
orange and brown but they pulled it off
and baker mayfield we were talking about
him yesterday and i think you probably
still stand by your statement and i
agree with you because i agree with you
yesterday
joe burrow if you had to pick take a pic
between joe burrow and baker mayfield
who would you go with i go with joe
burrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports